some guy just got pulled over for
driving it was a Tesla so I guess it was
a self-driving car but he was driving
with his Apple goggles on and the video
starts out all sort of nice he's he's
not touching the steering wheel
he's looks like he's casting a magic
spell of sorts cuz he's typing onto the
air so it it actually kind of looks like
he's Jordan Peterson you know like he's
doing one of these things with his hands
you know man but he's not but without
any of the wisdom you know without
insightful observations and then it
immediately cuts to the guy gets pulled
over by a police officer CS Lewis
observed in the great divorce the people
who are in Hell want to be there hell is
a place that you choose hell is where
you go by your own desire because you do
not turn your desire and behavior toward
God you turn it in the other direction
and you get what you want that's the
amazing thing about Freedom whether we
follow it in a proper way or we abuse it
is you tend to get what you want